- So, what is the origin of the law?
Well, we don't know for certain,
but we think it comes out of Mesopotamia.
No, not Hammurabi's Code,
that dates from the 18th century BCE.
Specifically, the city-state of Ur,
and then ruler Ur-Nammu,
around the year, 2100 BC.
Now there are some earlier references
to a set of laws from Urukagina
in the 24th century BCE,
but the Ur-Nammu code is the
oldest extant set of laws
that we still have.
It's written in a set
of if-then statements.
If someone does this, then this happens.
So not surprisingly, if
a man commits murder,
he shall be killed.
If a man commits robbery,
But what's particularly
interesting about this code
is that unlike the later
Babylonian codes like Hammurabi,
which purely focused on
retribution, an eye for an eye,
this creates a set of
monetary compensation
for certain acts.
So for example, if you
cut off a man's foot,
you owe that person 10 shekels of silver.
If you knock out someone's tooth,
you owe them two shekels of silver.
So this is fairly advanced stuff
in part of the Sumerian
Renaissance of the time.
And that is, as far as we can
tell, the origin of the law.